[Music]
all right our first mascot combines two
topics that most college students are
very familiar with Greek mythology and
binge drinking that's right it's the
center with a beer belly let's get them
out here
[Applause]
[Applause]
was absolutely incredible amazing
amazing Sentra with a beer belly that
was especially because his back legs
just drag yeah Curtis had a bad injury
yeah our next mascot is one of
spider-man's most feared enemies except
when his robot arms go haywire haywire
it's the tangled up Doc Ock
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
that guy's a mess all right and he
untangled I hear on tangled as hell
our next mascots very glamorous it's the
drawer where Johnny Depp keeps all of
his scarves let's get out of here
[Applause]
keeps his scars and go Johnny Depp Drago
[Applause]
forget the scarf I swear to God I
thought he was dead for a second that
was horrifying good God and you just
laughing it up all right this next
mascot was easily the most popular 90s
pop trio they're made out of pasta
it's rigatoni rigatoni rigatoni
[Applause]
[Applause]
missed and then got hit in the back of
the head
the ultimate indignity next up is one of
the saddest characters in Arabic
folklore the overweight genie stuck in a
lamp the overweight weenie
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
children everywhere horrify our final
mascot is a circus performer who also
has a sleep disorder it's the
narcoleptic trapeze artist where is he
[Music]
that was impressive look at that look at
that in slow motion that is accuracy
alright those are our NCAA mascots that
should never dunk and that was the proof
hotel my god
make your boobie shake again Jeannie
that's quality entertainment
you